How are you making sure that your highly sensitive
information is protected while you're running it?
Hi my name is Alex Greer from the IBM Cloud
team, and make sure to like and subscribe.
So, before I get started talking about
confidential computing I want to talk
a little bit about why it's such an exciting
field. So, confidential computing among other
reasons is exciting for the fact that we're seeing
cross-collaboration in the tech space to actually
drive the technology forward, and so it's awesome
to see people reaching across a competitive
aisle to do that, a lot of bright minds. The
second is that the technology is going to
directly complement the existing data encryption
paradigm that we have today and make it an even
more complete end-to-end story. So, before I get
into the actual technology and some of the use
and value behind it let's start with the
existing pillars of data encryption today.
So you start with protecting your data while
it's at-rest, so when you're storing it.
So we've got at-rest, you can think of this as
whatever information you'd like to. We'll just
represent it simply here. Now we have information
that we want to transit from point-to-point. So
in order to do that securely we need to protect
it while it's in-transit, so we say in-transit.
But what's missing in today's
story is this third pillar here.
What are you doing to protect it
while you're actually running it?
The groups you're going to have to protect
yourself against, one, are malicious actors
who want to do things like scrape that data.
You're also going to want to protect against
memory dumps, things of that nature. We have the
inevitable threat that we have to protect against
which is insider threats. And, in addition,
we also have a lot of collaboration that we
want to go on between us and either a trusted
vendor or even a trusted technology partner,
but at the same time we really don't want to
expose a piece of highly sensitive information
to them even though we want them to
be able to take advantage of it. So,
we've got also our partners and vendors here. How
can we ensure that this information is not only,
not visible to these parties, but also protected
from the worst case scenario? That's where
confidential computing comes in. So, let's talk
about what confidential computing looks like.
We earlier talked about the collaboration
across technology leaders in the space,
we at IBM are a part of the Confidential Computing
Consortium. So the definition that we follow for
confidential computing is as such, confidential
computing is a hardware-based technology that
allows for the physical partitioning of memory
at the server level. So let's draw our stack.
We've got our hardware level on the
bottom which is where the actual physical
partitioning of the memory is going to take place,
and then we have the middleware level, and then
for the example but not exclusive to we're going
to talk about any containerized abstraction of
this. So we're going to have containers here.
So what's taking place is that at the hardware
level we have that physical partitioning of the
memory which allows for you to actually
run that application in its own silo.
So the silo in the scenario that we've
painted here is going to be called an enclave.
So we've got an enclave here, one, two,
three, etcetera, etcetera, etcetera,
etcetera. So these enclaves can have applications
run in that that physically isolated environment,
but let's take a look into more detail
about what that actual enclave is.
So the enclave itself functions like a black
box so to speak. This black box or enclave
has that data that we spoke about earlier we'll
make it the same one from our previous example,
but what it also has in here are the set of
techniques or the things that or the actual
processing and the procedures for that processing
that information so we've got our techniques here.
What this system does in a scenario in
which we had the malicious actor from
earlier, we had the insider threat,
and we even had our own partners --
what it does is it has an encryption key that
it only extends out to the authorized program.
That allows for that authorized program to decrypt
the information running within this physically
isolated silo and to be able to actually perform
its set of processes. So, this authorized program
can do so, but that key is not extended to
the other parties. So that right privilege,
since it's not offered here, prevents the access
from for a malicious actor. It prevents the access
to an insider threat. And then finally,
it even prevents access to a partner.
What actual access is it preventing now? This
is access to modify that code as well as and
to view that data while it's actually inside this
physically partitioned silo. But what's really
important for our design is that we verify
that the interaction with that code or data
was what we hope for it to be. So
we need to have what we refer to as
attestation reports. So attestation reports
you can see here, attestation reports.
And just for good measure, we've got in here
that encryption key that we talked about.
So let's get back to the key value proposition we
just discussed. So what this secure enclave this
black box allowed us to do, it gave us a data
and code integrity that we didn't have before.
One, it reduced the visibility of
that data while it was being run
only to the the authorized program
itself. So, we have restricted visibility.
The second, is that it took that data and
it actually prevented these parties from
making any sort of undue modification
to the actual code itself. So no mod,
or unauthorized mod, and then what we were able
to do was verify the actual interaction with that
code and that data via attestation reports which
is very critical for corroborating the story
that our system is telling us. So now let's
look at the use cases that have been enabled.
So the first use case here we're going
to talk about is multiparty computing.
Multiparty computing coming down to right here
we're actually working with the technology
partner, it allows for us to take highly sensitive
information and exchange it with other parties
without actually exposing it so therefore what we
can do is we can share data sets, we can actually
collaborate, and perform functions commonly on top
of highly sensitive information. So you can think
about maybe a collaboration between two research
institutions who otherwise in the past had to
go around a very complicated path for actually
getting approval to exchange that information,
now they've got that quick and easy path
by simply not allowing that information to
be exposed to the other party. The next case
that we're going to talk about is IP. So IP,
you can think of that next great discovery
that your company is making perhaps you've
discovered some sort of pharmaceutical
innovation and you have the actual,
the blend or the chemical composition and the
other things that are unique about your solution
and you're wanting to actually share that with
another party, but again without exposing that
information to them. So this is another
great scenario where you're protected.
Now the final one, it's a real situation that we
all have to tackle today is that we give the keys
to the kingdom essentially to the people that we
trust and we hire, but an insider thread is always
a possibility. So we have to protect our workloads
from that possibility. So we have insider threats
here and now we've protected ourselves from even
the case in which our own turn on us. So now
that we've got the use cases laid out you can see
the clear value that is provided by confidential
computing. Confidential computing is focused on
protecting application data while you're actually
running it, and it allows for us to be able to
collaborate more freely with other parties as well
as protect ourselves in a new way from malicious
actors whether external or internal. Thank you for
listening. If you have questions please drop us
a line below. If you want to see more videos like
this in the future, please like and subscribe.
And don't forget, you can grow your skills and
earn a badge with IBM CloudLabs which are free
browser-based interactive Kubernetes labs.